[Applaudissements]
tu aies croisé un jour dans un
restaurant avec elodie frégé redire
hôtels et les bars quelque chose sinon
un père y est mort m oui j l'événement
accessible que du coup j'ai envie de
défendre beaugrand qui s'en sort pas mal
et on fait toiture par les arrêts
répétés des contrats mer - non mais est
ce qu'une amende si j'ai rien thierry
hancisse ici je les supplie sa fille
vers la tête de lit des eaux vives du
village donc tu te méfies pas c'est çà
et là c'est mieux
je crois que je peux à quoi de cracher
de glenview les championnats justement
ces divers va relier n'importe koué du
divertissement c'est ce que tu sais pas
faire